the Vienna Symphony Orchestra performing  Beethoven's seventh inside bonds concert  hall  and outside on the city's main square a  huge event for everyone here in the  birthplace of one of classical music's  most influential figures it's Heights  not truly decent company it's an  exciting way to experience this composer  his incredible creativity still speaks  to young people today he still exudes a  kind of an energy or a flow attracting a  new generation of Beethoven lovers is  one of the new directors main goals and  while Beethoven's music alone may still  have that power she's also brought in  contemporary dance to do the job  including this group from Sweden Goethe  Boggs operons dance company  54 events in 22 venues at over a century  old the Beethoven festival may have some  new twists  but even with all the changes ludwich is  still the local hero inside and out